Jake: 是在北京首都机场
Jake: We're at Beijing Capital Airport
Jake: 我们两位同学
Jake: Our two classmates
Jake: 在绝味鸭脖前进行了会晤
Jake: Met in front of Juewei Duck Neck
Jake: 进行了会晤
Jake: Had a meeting
Shure: 会悟这词用的就好
Shure: The word "meeting" is well used
Jake: 那是
Jake: Of course
Jake: 进行了一些简单的眼镜教导
Jake: We gave some simple instructions about the glasses
Jake: 比如说这个眼镜亮灯
Jake: For example, the glasses need to light up
Jake: 才能使用
Jake: Before you can use them
Jake: 大家可能意识到这个背景音乐啊
Jake: You might notice the background music
Jake: 可能也没有意识到这个背景音乐了
Jake: Or maybe you didn't notice the background music
Jake: 他是solo AI生存的这个title
Jake: It's the title for Solo AI Survival
Jake: 这个title
Jake: This title
Jake: 他他的这个名字叫ego life
Jake: Its name is "Ego Life"
Jake: 是我们的project name
Jake: It's our project name
Jake: 大家可以注意一下这个
Jake: You can pay attention to this
Jake: 一些歌词是用到了
Jake: Some of the lyrics
Jake: 我们就是都
Jake: They are all
Jake: 都是我们内部的一些梗
Jake: Our internal jokes
Jake: 有些人可能知道
Jake: Some people might know
Jake: 对这个人
Jake: This person
Jake: 秀儿哎
Jake: Shure, hey
Jake: 秀儿已经过去了
Jake: Shure is already gone
Jake: 因为这个秀儿这个镜头没有被捡到
Jake: Because the footage of Shure was not picked
Jake: 原因是
Jake: The reason is
Jake: 没时间了哈哈哈
Jake: There was no time, hahaha
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no
Shure: okay
Shure: Okay
Jake: 好欢迎大家来到我们的ego
Jake: Alright, welcome everyone to our Ego
Jake:好
Jake: Well
Shure: OK
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Jake: 啊我们
Jake: Uh, we
Jake: 刚刚
Jake: Just
Jake:啊  应该是
Jake: Uh, it should be
Alice: 就是这个就是这个
Alice: This is it, this is it
Jake: 尚柯欣我也没有时间剪
Jake: Shang Kexin, I didn't have time to edit
Jake: 所以不好意思
Jake: So, sorry about that
Jake: 她还没来
Jake: She's not here yet.
Jake: 还在楼下
Jake: Still downstairs.
Jake: 但是没关系
Jake: But it's okay.
Jake: 回头再剪好
Jake: We can edit it later.
Shure:  我们进入正题
Shure: Let's get to the point.
Jake: 我们来进入正题
Jake: Let's get to the point.
Jake: 今天呢我们原计划
Jake: So, today we originally planned...
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha
Jake: 如果一切都很顺利的话
Jake: If everything went smoothly...
Jake: 是这么个时间线
Jake: This would be the timeline.
Jake: 但是自然而然的很不顺利
Jake: But naturally, things didn't go smoothly.
Jake: 就是但是我们就往后顺延对吧
Jake: So, we'll just push things back, right?
Jake: 现改现在是几点
Jake: What's the time now?
Jake: 我们来现改
Jake: Let's change it now.
Jake:4点
Jake: 4 o'clock.
Jake: 4月07 4月07 好
Jake: April 07, April 07, okay.
Jake: 4点07
Jake: 4:07.
Jake: 我们进行到了introduction的一半的部分
Jake: We've reached halfway through the introduction.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈现改真的是
Jake: Hahahahaha, really changing it now.
Alice: 撒豆
Alice: Scatter beans.
Shure: 其他不重要
Shure: The rest doesn't matter.
Shure: start time对的
Shure: The start time is correct.
Shure: 咱们就OK了
Shure: We're good.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 你看看我们精准的控制到4.07
Shure: Look at us, precisely controlling it to 4:07.
Shure: 来进行我们这个introduction部分
Shure: Let's continue with the introduction part.
Jake: 好 再过哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, and then hahahahahahahaha
Jake: 再过20多小时之后
Jake: In over 20 hours from now...
Jake: 我们就结束了今天的introduction
Jake: We'll finish today's introduction.
Jake: 啊 然后下面我们会进行一些啊
Jake: Ah, then we'll move on to some...
Jake: 因为我们这7天前
Jake: Because 7 days ago...
Jake: 前6天我们让每个志愿者
Jake: In the first 6 days, we asked each volunteer...
Jake: 都装饰了自己的房间
Jake: To decorate their own rooms.
Jake: 装饰成了
Jake: Decorated into...
Jake: 一个主题来
Jake: A theme that...
Jake: 和这个ego earth
Jake: Corresponds with the ego earth...
Jake: 和这个earth day做一个呼应
Jake: And Earth Day.
Jake: 然后我们就很期待
Jake: So we're really looking forward to...
Jake: 各位志愿者的小屋装
Jake: Seeing the volunteers' little rooms.
Jake: 装饰成了什么样子
Jake: How is the decoration looking?
Jake: 对然后一会我们就会进行一个参观
Jake: Yes, and later we'll have a tour.
Jake: 然后参观之后呢
Jake: And after the tour...
Katrina: 我本来墙上贴了一个小狗的海报
Katrina: I originally had a poster of a puppy on the wall.
Jake: 我们会有一个QA的环节
Jake: We'll have a QA session.
Jake: 呃如果早来的观众呢
Jake: Uh, for those who arrived early,
Jake: 你们可能会经历一个找
Jake: you might experience a
Jake: 找这个ego币的一个环节
Jake: an activity to find ego coins.
Jake: 就是可能在一楼啊
Jake: Maybe on the first floor or
Jake: 二楼啊会有一些藏着的小贴画
Jake: the second floor, there are some hidden stickers.
Jake: 呃如果找到的话
Jake: Uh, if you find them,
Jake: 我们
Jake: we
Jake: 下面会有一个auction
Jake: we'll have an auction
Jake: auction就是拍卖
Jake: auction means a sale.
Jake:  我们会有一些小商品和
Jake: We'll have some small items and
Jake: 这个可能各位客人也会带来一些
Jake: maybe some guests will bring some
Jake: 小物件
Jake: small items.
Jake: 然后我们进行一个拍卖
Jake: Then we'll have an auction.
Jake: 就用我们发售的这个
Jake: Using the ego Coin we issued,
Jake: ego Coin已经上链了
Jake: the ego Coin is now on the blockchain.
Jake: 对这个十年
Jake: For the next ten years,
Jake: 这个十年
Jake: these ten years,
Jake: 大家保存好这个
Jake: everyone keep this
Jake: ego Coin
Jake: ego Coin safe.
Jake: 可能过十年之后大家就财富自由
Jake: Maybe after ten years, you'll achieve financial freedom.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈OK
Jake: Hahahahaha, OK.
Jake: 呃按照原计划5点半
Jake: Uh, according to the original plan, at 5:30,
Jake: 但是现在不知道是什么时候
Jake: but now we don't know when exactly.
Jake: 这个不重要
Jake: It's not important.
Jake: 就是我们就会进行啊
Jake: Then we'll proceed to
Jake: 到了party time
Jake: party time.
Jake: 就是吃吃喝喝
Jake: Just eating and drinking,
Jake: 玩玩乐乐
Jake: having fun.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright?
Jake: 会有一些音乐活动
Jake: There will be some music activities.
Jake: 大家也知道
Jake: As you all know,
Jake: 我们在看到这个阵仗特别的强势
Jake: we see this setup is really impressive.
Jake: 那我们来进行
Jake: So let's proceed
Jake: 这个就不管他了
Jake: and not worry about it.
Jake: 这个ego coin就是我们
Jake: This ego coin is our...
Jake: 就是大家记好这个
Jake: Everyone, remember this.
Jake: 这个标就是如有雷同就是假的
Jake: If you see this label, it means if there's any similarity, it's fake.
Jake: 就不要买
Jake: Don't buy it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 这个我们可能先
Jake: We might start by...
Jake: 我们先进行room tour
Jake: Let's do a room tour first.
Shure: room two
Shure: Room two.
Jake: room tour的活动吗
Jake: Are we doing a room tour?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Katrina: 还是等一下
Katrina: Or wait a bit.
Katrina: 你们先进去
Katrina: You guys go in first.
Katrina: 这个我要进去搜一下
Katrina: I need to search the place first.
Jake: 你要先进行啊
Jake: You need to go first?
Jake: 你要先收一下
Jake: You need to search first?
Jake: 那我们先进行QA的活动
Jake: Then let's do a QA session first.
Jake: 好一切都在我们的掌控之中
Jake: Okay, everything is under our control.
Jake: 一切都在计划之中
Jake: Everything is going as planned.
Shure: 就我们我们这个项目只有一位
Shure: Well, in our project, we only have one...
Shure: 只有一位是这人
Shure: We only have one person who...
Shure: 然后就是他就是计划非常的周密
Shure: And that person is very meticulous with the plan.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 她对计划担当
Jake: She is in charge of the plan.
Jake: 我们可以
Jake: We can...
Jake: 那趁她在装饰的时候
Jake: While she's decorating,
Jake: 我们可能可以再去看一下这个小影片
Jake: We can watch this little video.
Jake: 里边有一些
Jake: There are some...
Jake: 一些可以回味的地方
Jake: Some memorable parts.
Shure: 回味的地方
Shure: Memorable parts.
Jake:哪儿去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Shure: 还回味一遍
Shure: Relive it again.
Jake: 刚刚那个架子呢
Jake: Where's that shelf?
Jake: 就是每天8点了
Jake: It's already 8 o'clock.
Jake: 我们的Katrina
Jake: Our Katrina...
Jake: 那个架子
Jake: That shelf.
Jake: Katrina同学
Jake: Katrina will...
Jake: 她就会叫我们起床
Jake: She will wake us up.
Jake: 我们的J人同学会叫我们起床
Jake: Our J person will wake us up.
Jake: 是吧j人
Jake: Right, J person?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 对古希腊掌管
Jake: In ancient Greece, there was a god
Jake: 掌管闹钟的神
Jake: The god who managed alarms
Shure: 他的闹钟会准时的把我叫醒
Shure: His alarm clock will wake me up on time
其他人：意思就是别人是叫不醒的
Others: Meaning no one else can wake you up
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then
Jake: 这是主歌
Jake: This is the verse
Jake: 这个这是副歌
Jake: And this is the chorus
Jake: 副歌就没有什么意义
Jake: The chorus doesn't mean much
Jake: 这就是AI写的了
Jake: This was written by AI
Jake: 我们也听不看不懂也听不懂
Jake: We can't understand it, nor can we listen to it
Jake: 啊这就是你啊这是
Jake: Ah, this is you, this is
Jake: 就是这个歌词是你
Jake: This lyric is you
Jake: 虽然人不是你 就是
Jake: Although the person isn't you, it is
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake: 人 supposed to be me
Jake: The person supposed to be me
Shure: supposed to be me okay
Shure: supposed to be me, okay
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Jake: 就是他是我们的鼓手
Jake: He is our drummer
Jake: 对你你介绍一下吧
Jake: Yes, you introduce yourself
Jake: 你是谁啊
Jake: Who are you?
Jake: 我我我我是一个
Jake: I, I, I am a
Shure: 混子哈哈哈
Shure: A loafer, hahaha
Shure: 混子鼓手
Shure: A loafer drummer
Shure: 对就是
Shure: Yes, just
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Shure: 在在这个大家庭里充当一些氛围担当
Shure: Playing the role of atmosphere maker in this big family
Shure: 就是没事给大家清晨嚎一嗓子
Shure: Just occasionally roaring in the morning
Shure: 京剧什么的
Shure: Peking opera or something
Shure: 对就是叫大家起床
Shure: Yes, just waking everyone up
Shure: 大概是小百灵是吧
Shure: Probably a little lark, right?
Shure: 嗯对
Shure: Hmm, right
Shure: 这个小黄毛是我们的谢彬竹同学
Shure: This little yellow hair is our classmate Xie Binzhu
Jake: 对这位这位同学
Jake: Yes, this student here
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Jake: 红衣服的同学
Jake: The one in red
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Shure: 他是一个不良少年
Shure: He was a delinquent
Shure: 但是被我们的项目给改造好了
Shure: But he has been reformed by our project
Shure: 这就是我们Eagle life的魅力
Shure: This is the charm of our Eagle life.
Shure: 你看看他
Shure: Look at him.
Shure: 曾经从来没有露出过这么灿烂的笑容
Shure: He has never shown such a bright smile before.
Shure: 好了这段就不用看了
Shure: Alright, you don't need to watch this part.
Shure: 对对对这段就可以不用看了
Shure: Yeah, yeah, you don't need to watch this part.
Shure: 想看的话我
Shure: If you want to watch it
Shure: 一会贴脸给大家每人看一遍好吗
Shure: I'll show it to each of you up close later, okay?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 如果想看的同学
Jake: If anyone wants to watch,
Jake: 我们可以现场给他表演一遍
Jake: we can perform it live for them.
Jake: 我们6个人的眼镜都在哈哈
Jake: All six of us have glasses on, haha.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我们现在欢迎我们的志愿者Lucia
Jake: Now let's welcome our volunteer, Lucia.
Lucia: 谢谢大家
Lucia: Thank you, everyone.
Jake: 哈喽Lucia
Jake: Hello, Lucia.
Lucia: 谢谢大家
Lucia: Thank you, everyone.
Lucia: 我是不是我傻
Lucia: Am I silly?
Lucia: 我要去现在是干嘛啊
Lucia: What am I supposed to do now?
Jake:好呃
Jake: Okay, um.
Lucia: 我我是去收拾还是去怎么样可以啊
Lucia: Should I clean up or what should I do now?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 对稍微收拾一下然后就稍微tour一下
Jake: Yeah, just tidy up a bit and then give a quick tour.
Lucia: 啊OK好好好
Lucia: Ah, okay, alright, alright.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 那我们先吐会儿
Shure: Let's take a break first.
Jake: 呃我们还是先QA吧
Jake: Um, let's do a QA session first.
Jake: 一切都在掌握之中么
Jake: Everything's under control, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 那下面两位
Jake: Now, the next two,
Jake: 她们
Jake: they
Jake: 她们来了
Jake: they're here.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Right?
Jake: 那我们欢迎
Jake: Let's welcome
Jake: 尚柯欣同学和张夏梦微同学
Jake: Shang Kexin and Zhang Xiamengwei.
Jake: 要不坐
Jake: How about sitting
Alice: 啊坐哪
Alice: Ah, where should we sit?
Jake: 坐找个地坐吧
Jake: Find a place to sit.
Alice: 我们能坐这吗
Alice: Can we sit here?
Jake: 当然可以好的
Jake: Of course, sure.
Alice: 好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 能坐这吗
Alice: Can I sit here?
Jake: 坐坐坐
Jake: Sit, sit, sit.
Alice: 就这
Alice: Right here?
Alice: 太靠前了
Alice: This is too far forward.
Jake: 再再去到Tasha那一段吧
Jake: Go over to Tasha's part.
Jake: 到Tasha这一段
Jake: Go to Tasha's part.
Jake: Tasha
Jake: Tasha.
Shure: 好给大家看一遍他傻的部分是吧
Shure: Okay, let’s show everyone Tasha's part, right?
Jake: 对对看一遍Tasha的歌词
Jake: Yes, yes, show Tasha's lyrics.
Jake: 看一遍Tasha的歌词
Jake: Show Tasha's lyrics.
Jake: 因为给他介绍一下她的这个小
Jake: Because we're introducing her little...
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 小甜点
Jake: ...dessert.
Shure: 他俩的部分在哪
Shure: Where's their part?
Jake: 我也不知道在哪就大概
Jake: I don't know exactly, just roughly...
Jake: 可能在这吧
Jake: Maybe here.
Jake: 啊这是修是吧
Jake: Ah, this is Shure, right?
Jake: 修下面就是他
Jake: Under Shure is him.
Shure: 我们的Tasha
Shure: Our Tasha.
Jake:我们的Tasha
Jake: Our Tasha.
Shure: 也就是我们
Shure: Which means...
Shure: 今天所有甜点的甜点的厨师
Shure: ...the chef for all the desserts today is Tasha.
Shure: 就是Tasha
Shure: It’s Tasha.
Shure: 然后刚刚在歌词里介绍了一下对
Shure: And she was just introduced in the lyrics, right.
Jake: 对在歌词里介绍
Jake: Yes, introduced in the lyrics.
Jake: 现在是介绍Alice是吧
Jake: Now it's Alice's introduction, right?
Jake: 是吧 人呢Alice
Jake: Right? Where's Alice?
Shure: 爱丽丝跑了
Shure: Alice ran away.
Shure: 爱丽丝梦游仙境去啊
Shure: Alice went to Wonderland.
Alice: 啊在这儿呢
Alice: Ah, I'm here.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 好好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 好好好那就介绍完
Shure: Okay, okay, that's the end of the introductions.
Jake: 介绍介绍完了
Jake: Introductions are over.
Jake: 那我们来QA
Jake: Now let's do Q&A.
Shure: 还是回到QA吧对
Shure: Let's go back to Q&A, right.
Jake: 来进行到QA 2024运动会
Jake: Let's move on to the 2024 Q&A session.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈 稍有串戏
Jake: Hahaha, a little mix-up.
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So we...
Jake: 有一个给观众的回答问题时间的环节
Jake: ...have a segment for answering audience questions.
Jake: 如果答对抢答的环节
Jake: If you answer correctly during the quiz round
Jake: 抢答对的话就会拿到一个ego币
Jake: If you get it right, you'll get an ego coin
Jake: 这个ego币可以用来换取甜品
Jake: This ego coin can be used to exchange for desserts
Jake: 和为未来财富自由做准备
Jake: And prepare for financial freedom in the future
Jake: 现在现在一个币每一个的价格是
Jake: Right now, each coin's price is
Jake: 现在是多少钱
Jake: How much is it now
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Jake: 3块人民币
Jake: 3 RMB
Jake: 好嘞现在每个一个币3块人民币
Jake: Okay, so now each coin is 3 RMB
Jake: 然后明天明天我们再看看多少钱
Jake: And tomorrow we'll see how much it is again
Jake: 那我们第0题
Jake: So our first question
Jake: 世界地球日是哪一天
Jake: When is Earth Day?
Jake: 你你举什么手
Jake: Why are you raising your hand
Jake: 我们
Jake: We
Jake: 我们得抢
Jake: We need to buzz in
Jake: 拿怎么抢呢
Jake: How do we buzz in
Shure: 抢举手吗
Shure: By raising our hands?
Jake: 举手那好
Jake: Raising hands, okay
Shure: 白衣少年
Shure: The guy in white
Shure: 他选择了2B
Shure: He chose 2B
Shure: 2B杨老板
Shure: 2B, Jake
Shure: 正确吗
Shure: Is that correct?
Jake: 我觉得挺对的
Jake: I think it's right
Shure: 你觉得挺对
Shure: You think it's right
Shure: 那你觉得这题应该值几个一钩币
Shure: How many ego coins should this question be worth?
Jake:我觉得可能不太值
Jake: I think maybe not much
Jake: 因为他是地0题
Jake: Because it's the first question
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 啊这是一个热身
Jake: It's a warm-up
Shure: 热身
Shure: Warm-up
Jake: 来让大家知道怎么举手
Jake: To let everyone know how to raise their hands
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 但是但是
Shure: But but
Shure: 我觉得第一个回答问题的同学
Shure: I think the first person to answer
Shure: 勇气可嘉
Shure: Is very brave
Shure: 我们应该发出EGO币币
Shure: We should give out an ego coin
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 支持一下
Jake: Let's support that
Jake: 来
Jake: Here
Jake: 领了我们的第一个ego币
Jake: Take your first ego coin
Shure: 我们的EGO币军事上链
Shure: Our EGO coins are now on the military chain.
Shure: 然后大家那个活动结束
Shure: After the event ends,
Shure: 可以找谢斌如同学
Shure: you can find Xie Binru
Shure: 兑换到自己的那个Mata Max的钱包里面
Shure: to exchange them into your Mata Max wallet.
Shure: 然后下一题
Shure: Now, the next question.
Shure: 首次庆祝世界地球日是哪一年
Shure: In what year was the first Earth Day celebrated?
Shure: a 1960年b 1970年c 1980年d 2024年
Shure: a) 1960 b) 1970 c) 1980 d) 2024
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 选b
Jake: Choose b.
Shure: 选b他选择二b
Shure: He chose b.
Shure: 还有哪位同学有不同意见
Shure: Does anyone have a different opinion?
Shure: 白毛同学放手
Shure: Bai Mao, put your hand down.
Shure: 选b
Shure: Choose b.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈勇气可嘉
Jake: Hahaha, brave choice!
Shure: 他选择的这个日子
Shure: The date he chose
Shure: 就是那种班级倒数第一同学
Shure: is like the answer chosen by the last place student in the class,
Shure: 看一眼题都不会选的答案
Shure: who wouldn't even look at the question.
Shure: 还有还有同学吗
Shure: Anyone else?
其他人：我选c
Others: I choose c.
Shure: 你选c是吧
Shure: You choose c, right?
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Alice: 举手
Alice: Raise your hand.
Shure: 看来我们的这个选项非常
Shure: It seems our options are very
Shure: 的焦灼大家
Shure: competitive, everyone.
Shure: 大家难分伯仲
Shure: It's hard to choose.
Shure: 只能说那我们公布一下正确答案
Shure: Let's announce the correct answer.
Jake: 我查一下哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Let me check, hahaha.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 选B选B哈哈哈哈
Jake: Choose B, haha.
Jake: 选b选b
Jake: Choose b, choose b.
Jake: 1970年
Jake: 1970.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 又是这位白衣少年
Shure: Again, it's that guy in white.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Jake: 好我们来到了
Jake: Okay, we have come to
其他人：每次D都是那个迷惑性最强的选项吗
Others: Is D always the most confusing option?
Shure: 第二题谁是世界地球日的创始人
Shure: Second question, who is the founder of Earth Day?
Shure: a艾尔伯特爱因斯坦b盖盖
Shure: a) Albert Einstein b) Gay Gay
其他人：我抢答A
Others: I'll buzz in for A.
Shure: 盖洛德尼德尼尔森c休硕d尚可辛
Shure: Gaylord Nelson, c Shure, d Shang Kexin
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 谁举手快啊
Jake: Who raised their hand the fastest?
Jake: 你看出来吗
Jake: Can you tell?
Shure: 我我我感觉相机小哥你最你最快
Shure: I, I, I feel like the camera guy was the fastest.
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time.
其他人：那要不我看大家都很喜欢B那就B
Others: Well, since everyone seems to like B, let's go with B.
Shure: 他选择了b
Shure: He chose B.
Jake: 还有还有没有
Jake: Any other choices?
Shure: 还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any different answers?
其他人：我选D
Others: I choose D.
Shure: d
Shure: D.
其他人：众所周知3   所以我选C
Others: As everyone knows, 3, so I choose C.
Shure: 好选择
Shure: Good choice.
Shure: 那个白衣少年
Shure: That boy in white.
Shure: 啊好的好的
Shure: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure: 那我们想必
Shure: So, I guess
Shure: 大家已经知道
Shure: everyone already knows
Shure: 这个正确答案是什么了吧选择
Shure: what the correct answer is, right? Choose.
Alice: D
Alice: D.
Jake: C
Jake: C.
Alice: D
Alice: D.
Shure: 选择b其实是啊
Shure: Actually, choosing B is, uh,
Jake:唉
Jake: Ugh.
Shure: 给大家科普一下
Shure: Let me explain to everyone,
Shure: 这个盖洛德尼尔森
Shure: this Gaylord Nelson.
Shure: 大家可能不知道他是谁吧
Shure: You probably don't know who he is, right?
Shure: 他是这个世界地球日的创始人
Shure: He is the founder of Earth Day.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 好的那个
Shure: Okay, so
Shure: 这这个题我觉得难度系数非常的大
Shure: I think this question was really difficult.
Shure: 需要奖励两个币子来同学
Shure: We need to reward two coins to this student.
Shure: 但鉴于刚刚那个选择d选项的同学
Shure: But considering the student who chose D,
Shure: 勇气非常可嘉
Shure: the courage is commendable.
Shure: 我觉得也应该奖励一位
Shure: I think we should also reward one.
其他人：谢谢我的荣幸
Others: Thank you, it's my honor.
Alice: 笑死了
Alice: So funny.
Shure: 选c选项那个就是
Shure: The one who chose C, that is...
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 就是大聪明
Shure: Just a big smart guy
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 哎呀后面同学把嘴闭上
Shure: Hey, the student in the back, shut your mouth
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you still have battery?
Shure: 啊第三个
Shure: Uh, the third one
Jake:哈哈哈哈刚充上
Jake: Hahaha, just charged it
Shure: 哪个重要的政府机构
Shure: Which important government agency
Shure: 是在第一个世界地球日后成立的
Shure: was established after the first Earth Day?
Shure: a国家公园管理局b美国农业局c
Shure: a) National Park Service b) U.S. Department of Agriculture c)
Shure: 美国环境保护局d
Shure: Environmental Protection Agency d)
Shure: 美国鱼类和野生动物服务局
Shure: U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service
其他人：选C
Others: Choose C
Shure: 选c还有不同答案吗
Shure: Choose C, any other answers?
Shure: 选最长是吗
Shure: Choose the longest one, right?
Shure: OK选d
Shure: OK, choose D
Shure: 还有其他答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
其他人：第二个
Others: The second one
Shure: 他选了b
Shure: He chose B
Alice: 选A
Alice: Choose A
Shure: 你你不要参加回答
Shure: You, you don't participate in answering
Alice: 我不在范围啊
Alice: Am I out of scope?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Shure: 要不这位同学你选一下
Shure: How about you, this student, you choose
Shure: 好公布一下正确答案吧杨老板
Shure: Alright, let's announce the correct answer, Jake
Jake: 美国环境保护局
Jake: Environmental Protection Agency
Shure: OK
Shure: 我觉得这题也值
Shure: I think this question is worth it too
Jake: 确实太难了
Jake: Indeed, it's too hard
Shure: 两个币子
Shure: Two coins
Alice: 很快你就可以赎走我了
Alice: Soon you can redeem me
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：我俩我合俩合资
Others: The two of us will chip in together
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 然后下面第四题
Shure: And now, the fourth question
Shure: 大约有多少人
Shure: About how many people
Shure: 参加了第一个世界地球日
Shure: participated in the first Earth Day?
Shure: a 30万b 200万c 300人d 2,000万人
Shure: a) 300,000 b) 2 million c) 300 d) 20 million
其他人：选c
Others: Choose C
其他人：象牙还能有300人吗
Others: Could there even be 300 people at Ivory?
Shure: 他选择了c
Shure: He chose C.
Shure: 这位同学
Shure: This student here,
Shure: 你一直默默无闻
Shure: You've always been quiet.
Shure: 你要不回答一下
Shure: Why don't you answer something?
Shure: 有人选c的
Shure: Someone chose C.
Shure: 你选什么啊
Shure: What did you choose?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 他选第四个
Shure: He chose the fourth one.
Shure: 他们两个选了一个极端
Shure: They both chose extremes.
Shure: 一个选了300人
Shure: One chose 300 people,
Shure: 一个选了2,000万人
Shure: The other chose 20 million people.
Shure: 还有不同答案吗
Shure: Are there any different answers?
其他人：那中一个30万
Others: Somewhere in between, 300,000.
Shure: 你看看这个头脑
Shure: Look at this brain.
Alice: 中庸之道
Alice: The middle way.
Shure: 中庸之道对
Shure: The middle way, right.
Shure: 选择了对冲
Shure: Hedging the choice.
Shure: 选择了30万还有吗
Shure: Chose 300,000. Any more?
其他人：选个B吧
Others: Let's go with B.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 我就知道
Shure: I knew it.
其他人：总有人是对的
Others: Someone is always right.
Shure: 对公布答案
Shure: Yes, let's reveal the answer.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 2000万人
Jake: 20 million people.
Alice: 哇这么多人
Alice: Wow, so many people.
Shure: 没有想到吧
Shure: You didn't expect that, right?
Shure: 就是说明这个日子非常重要
Shure: This shows how important this day is.
Shure: 第一次办就有这么多人参加
Shure: So many people participated the first time it was held.
Shure: 哪哪位同学选择2,000万来着
Shure: Which student chose 20 million?
Shure: 白衣小哥这个
Shure: The guy in the white shirt.
Shure: 这个问题两个币子
Shure: This question is worth two coins.
Jake: 这个可以稍作科普
Jake: This could use some explanation.
Jake: 因为这个世界地球日
Jake: Because this Earth Day,
Jake: 它主要在高校之间
Jake: It's mainly held among colleges.
Jake: 高校内进行
Jake: Within colleges.
Jake: 然后高校的那帮人
Jake: And then those college people,
Jake: 然后高校的那帮人对都搞得进去
Jake: Those college people, yeah, they all get involved.
Jake: 都搞得进去
Jake: They all get involved.
Shure: 所以我们有2,000万人参加
Shure: So we have 20 million people participating.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Hmm, yes.
Jake: 里边是最最重要的一个活动
Jake: This is the most important event inside.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 好的下一题
Shure: Okay, next question.
Shure: 今年的世界地球日的主题是什么
Shure: What's the theme of this year's Earth Day?
Shure: a投资我们的星球
Shure: a. Invest in Our Planet
Shure: b动员地球
Shure: b. Mobilize the Earth
Shure: c星球对抗塑料d 10亿绿色行动
Shure: c. Planet versus Plastic d. Billion Acts of Green
Shure: 请抢答
Shure: Quick answer, please.
其他人：选a
Others: Choose a.
Shure: 选a是吗
Shure: Choose a, right?
Shure: 还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
Shure: 来C4D你
Shure: Come on, C4D, you.
其他人：4D
Others: 4D.
Shure: 你们俩谁先他他他
Shure: Who between you two, him, him, him?
其他人：她吧她吧
Others: Her, her.
Shure: 他那他你确定
Shure: Him, then. Are you sure?
Shure: 4D还是让给他
Shure: 4D, or let him?
其他人：那我2B好吧
Others: Then I'll go with 2B, okay?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 好的BD
Shure: Okay, BD.
Shure: CA然后你是c是吧好的
Shure: CA, and you are c, right? Okay.
Shure: 公布正确答案
Shure: Announcing the correct answer.
Jake:c
Jake: c.
Shure: CC选项今年的主题叫做planet versus plastic
Shure: CC, the theme this year is called "Planet versus Plastic."
Shure: 就是星球对抗塑料
Shure: Which means "Planet versus Plastic."
Shure: 是我们今年的世界进球日的主题
Shure: That's our theme for Earth Day this year.
Shure: 然后恭喜
Shure: And congratulations.
Shure: 像像相机同学
Shure: To the camera student.
其他人：其他主题都啥年用的
Others: What about the other themes?
其他人：是有过的还是没有的
Others: Have they been used before or not?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 好问题
Jake: Good question.
Jake: 我们也不知道
Jake: We don't know either.
其他人：这显像是生造出来的还是
Others: Were these themes made up, or...
其他人：从音节里面选
Others: ...were they chosen from syllables?
Shure: 不这个
Shure: No, this...
Jake: 这所有的题目都是几比几十
Jake: All the questions are like ten to dozens.
Shure: 但是答案保真的这个是
Shure: But the answers are guaranteed to be accurate.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
其他人：除了答案保真题目都不保真是吗
Other: So, only the answers are authentic, not the questions, right?
Shure: 啊没有没有这个
Shure: No, no, that's not the case.
Shure: 其他确实是都没有
Shure: Everything else is indeed not authentic.
Shure: 没有出现过的都是胡搜出来的
Shure: Those that haven't appeared are just made up.
Shure: 然后这题三个币子
Shure: And this question is worth three coins.
Shure: 这怎么还有分尾组呢
Shure: Why are there still sub-groups?
Tasha: 这12块钱就到手了
Tasha: These 12 bucks are in the bag.
Shure: 下
Shure: Next.
Shure: 下一题第7题
Shure: Next question, number 7.
Shure: 地球的南极冰啊
Shure: The ice in Earth's Antarctic.
Shure: 地球的南极冰盖
Shure: The Antarctic ice sheet.
Shure: 锁定了多少比百分比的淡水
Shure: How much percentage of freshwater does it lock in?
Shure: a大约50%
Shure: a) Around 50%
Shure: b大约70% c大约90% d大约30%
Shure: b) Around 70% c) Around 90% d) Around 30%
其他人：抢答C
Other: Answer C
Shure: C2B
Shure: C to B
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 你好啊
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Katrina: 早上好
Katrina: Good morning.
Jake: 早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Katrina: 起床了
Katrina: Time to get up.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Shure: 好那没有其他的选项了
Shure: Okay, no other options.
Katrina: 没有其他的
Katrina: No others.
Shure: 公布答案杨老板 90%
Shure: Announce the answer, Jake. 90%.
Jake:90
Jake: 90.
Shure: 我们其实世界呃
Shure: Actually, our world...
Shure: 就是地球上最大的淡水资源
Shure: The largest freshwater resource on Earth...
Shure: 都是南极冰盖锁定的
Shure: Is locked in the Antarctic ice sheet.
Shure: 对所以是90%
Shure: So it's 90%.
Shure: 然后这题也三个币子吧
Shure: And this question is worth three coins too.
Alice: 提问冰盖跟奶盖什么意
Alice: Question, what's the link between ice sheets and milk foam?
Alice: 什么关系
Alice: What's the connection?
Shure: 呃好问题
Shure: Uh, good question.
Jake:好问题
Jake: Good question.
Shure: 就是在我说说你听听
Shure: Let me explain, listen up.
Shure: 在想当初大约3,500万年前
Shure: Think back about 35 million years ago...
Shure: 继女娲补天的时候
Shure: After Nüwa mended the sky
Shure: 创造了一个双胞胎
Shure: She created a pair of twins
Shure: 一个叫冰盖
Shure: One named Binggai
Shure: 一个叫奶盖
Shure: The other named Naigai
Shure: 对大概就是这么回事您说
Shure: Yeah, that's pretty much the story, you know
其他人：我有一个问题
Other: I have a question
其他人：在我印象里它的淡水占72%,但是冰盖是90%
Other: In my impression, it holds 72% of the freshwater, but the ice cap is 90%
其他人：但你这个问是它储存多少淡水而是冰盖有多少水
Other: But your question is about how much freshwater it stores, not how much water the ice cap holds
其他人：所以你check一下
Other: So you might want to check that
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Shure: 他是就是占占了全球淡水的多少
Shure: It's about how much of the global freshwater it contains
其他人：但是你这个是淡水，90%只是却不是淡水
Other: But you're talking about freshwater, 90% is not just freshwater
其他人：你可以看一下有没有那个搜一下
Other: You can look it up, search for it
Tasha: 你们你们你们一共多少个人的团队
Tasha: How many people are in your team?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh wow
Shure: 有人提出了challenge
Shure: Someone raised a challenge
Shure: 杨老板南极波盖
Shure: Jake, look up the Antarctic ice cap
Jake: 直播搜索
Jake: Live search
其他人：波盖的面积
Other: The area of the ice cap
其他人：已超过这个14后面
Other: Exceeds this number, 14
其他人：后面六个零平方公里
Other: Followed by six zeros in square kilometers
其他人：厚度达到4公里以上所含的冰量
Other: The thickness reaches over 4 kilometers, and the amount of ice
其他人：庞大相当于地球所有淡水水量
Other: Is equivalent to about 70% of all the freshwater on Earth
其他人： 的约70%
Other: About 70%
Lucia: 嗯啊
Lucia: Hmm, yeah
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Lucia: 嗯退退
Lucia: Hmm, step back
其他人：啊
Other: Ah
Alice: 是水有70%陆地有30% 70%的水里有是90%的水才是
Alice: It's 70% water and 30% land. Of the 70% water, 90% of it is...
其他人：如果你把那个淡字去掉就是90
Other: If you remove the word "fresh," it's 90%
Lucia: 大家好认真哈哈哈
Lucia: Everyone is so serious, haha
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Lucia: 没想到哈哈哈
Lucia: Didn't expect that, haha
Shure: 是的那
Shure: Yes, so
Alice:对因为有的水不是淡水
Alice: Yes, because some water is not freshwater
Shure: 转移一下资产
Shure: Let's transfer some assets
Jake: 转移资产
Jake: Transfer assets
其他人：但我们确定哪 三个是原来的
Other: But we need to confirm which three are the original ones
其他人：好随便给你什么
Other: Okay, just give you anything
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 然后那我们再奖励一枚币子给
Shure: So, let's reward a coin to
Shure: 查出正确答案的同学
Shure: The student who finds the correct answer
Shure: 非常好
Shure: Very good
Shure: 那么下一题
Shure: Now, the next question
Shure: 地球的南极
Shure: The Earth's South Pole
其他人：哎哎
Others: Hey hey
Shure: 他让我梅开二度的难堪
Shure: He made me feel embarrassed twice
Shure: 从太阳到地球
Shure: From the sun to the Earth
Shure: 阳光需要多长时间到达
Shure: How long does it take for sunlight to reach?
Shure: 这个
Shure: This
Shure: 其实是我们好像高中那种经常算的
Shure: It's actually something we often calculated in high school
Shure: 哎呦已经有两位同学举手了
Shure: Oh, two students have already raised their hands
Shure: 8分19秒
Shure: 8 minutes 19 seconds
Shure: 哎我其实你们两个同时举手
Shure: Hey, you two raised your hands at the same time
Shure: 那你们还有其他答案吗
Shure: Do you have any other answers?
其他人：我选B
Others: I choose B
Shure: 你选D20天
Shure: You choose D, 20 days
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：啊
Others: Ah
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 你知道这个地意味着什么意思吗
Shure: Do you know what this D means?
Shure: 就是我们的表转了20圈
Shure: It means our clock has turned 20 times
Shure: 才有一天会看到太阳
Shure: Then we would see the sun in one day
Lucia: 太哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice: 确保一定有一个正确答案
Alice: Make sure there's at least one correct answer
Alice: 为我们的顺利进行
Alice: For our smooth progress
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah ah ah
Shure: 这这位同学纠正了我的
Shure: This student corrected my
Shure: 我的错误
Shure: My mistake
Shure: 是表转了40圈
Shure: It's 40 turns of the clock
Shure: 是20圈啊
Shure: It's 20 turns, right?
Shure: 对对对我舒服了
Shure: Yes yes yes, now I feel relieved
Shure: 哎正确答案就谁
Shure: Hey, who got the correct answer?
Shure: 是吧对
Shure: Right, yes
Shure: 是8分19秒
Shure: It's 8 minutes 19 seconds
Shure: 大家还记得那个怎么算的吗
Shure: Does everyone still remember how to calculate it?
其他人：谁问你了
Others: Who asked you?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：距离除以光速
Others: Distance divided by speed of light
Shure: 是是就其实就是这么简单对
Shure: Yes, yes, actually it's just that simple.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：是这样的
Others: Exactly.
其他人：所以如果真的需要海天的话
Others: So if we really need the sky and sea...
其他人：那那南极冰盖肯定不会占地球的
Others: Then the Antarctic ice sheet definitely wouldn't cover the Earth...
Tasha: 二九九七九二四五八
Tasha: 299792458.
其他人：占水70% 那起码太阳没了
Others: Covering 70% water, at least the sun is gone.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Lucia: 但问题太阳是持续发光
Lucia: But the thing is, the sun keeps shining.
Lucia: 他又不是唰一下然后又熄灭
Lucia: It's not like it just turns off suddenly.
Shure: 你们你们2位
Shure: You two...
Shure: 每人两个
Shure: Each take two.
其他人： 一方面感谢的是这个样子的话如果太阳坏掉了的话
Others: On one hand, if the sun breaks down...
其他人： 也还能
Others: We still can...
Lucia: 你还能再活20天哈哈哈
Lucia: You can live for another 20 days, haha.
Shure: 很乐观
Shure: Very optimistic.
其他人： 我先看 了8分钟之前
Others: I watched 8 minutes ago...
Lucia: 太阳冷却了
Lucia: The sun has cooled.
Lucia: 我们还能再活20天
Lucia: We can live another 20 days.
Katrina: 哈别把谢斌竹搞蒙了
Katrina: Haha, don't confuse Xie Binzhu.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question.
Lucia: 哈哈哈神经病
Lucia: Hahaha, crazy.
Shure: 陨石
Shure: Meteorites.
Shure: 为什么每次都能精准的砸到陨石坑
Shure: Why do they always hit the craters precisely?
Lucia: 谁把这个问题加进去了
Lucia: Who added this question?
Lucia: 哈哈哈这个问题哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, this question, haha.
其他人：谁问的这个问题
Others: Who asked this question?
Shure: 这是一个开放性问题
Shure: This is an open-ended question.
Shure: 根据你们的回答
Shure: Based on your answers...
Shure: 我进行判断
Shure: I'll make a judgment.
Shure: 给你们发币
Shure: And give you points.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Shure: 这个每人都来回答一下来
Shure: Everyone answer this one.
其他人：我觉得
Others: I think...
其他人：这可以转化成一个前述范式的问题
Others: This can be turned into a previous paradigm question.
其他人：就是它这个因果的问题
Other: It's about the cause and effect issue.
其他人：就是有隐之坑
Other: There's a hidden pitfall.
其他人：这是一个前置命题
Other: This is a precondition.
其他人：然后它可以导致后面的问题
Other: And it can lead to subsequent problems.
其他人：那么如果前面问题是1的话
Other: So if the initial issue is 1,
其他人：后面的问题肯定是一个有陨石坑
Other: The following issue will definitely have a pitfall.
其他人：所以说肯定有隐士
Other: So there will definitely be a hermit.
其他人：但如果前面那个没有隐士坑的话
Other: But if there's no pitfall in the beginning,
其他人：它这个这个
Other: Then this problem...
其他人：这个病题始终是真的
Other: This problem remains true.
Tasha: 他已经得满分了
Tasha: He already got full marks.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：虽然很想同意这个话
Other: Although I really want to agree with this,
其他人：但是呢还
Other: But still...
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 老婆饼为什么没有老婆啊
Katrina: Why does Wife Cake not have a wife in it?
其他人：陨石坑为什么一定要有陨石
Other: Why does a crater have to have a meteor?
Tasha: 你刚刚是不是还想说嘿
Tasha: Were you about to say "hey"?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure: 反抗辩手
Shure: Counter-arguer.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
其他人：因为我觉得老婆给他老婆没有明事的
Other: Because I think the wife didn't clarify it.
其他人：明事的一个
Other: Clarify a...
其他人：谁造成谁的
Other: Who caused whom?
其他人：但是陨石坑是由陨石造成的
Other: But a crater is caused by a meteor.
Lucia: 你不能说是老婆饼是由老婆造成的
Lucia: You can't say a Wife Cake is made by a wife.
其他人：哦有一个
Other: Oh, there's a...
其他人：这样的一个哦
Other: There's such a...
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 那我们宣判反方一
Shure: So we declare the opposition lost.
Shure: 正方一变赢了
Shure: The proposition won the debate.
Shure: 好你先思考然后
Shure: Okay, you think it over first...
其他人：我觉得是因为陨石自带GPS系统它总能精确的定位到陨石坑对不对有没有道理
Other: I think it's because meteors come with a GPS system, they can always precisely locate the crater, right? Makes sense?
Shure: 我觉得她说这个也不无道理
Shure: I think what she said makes sense too.
Shure: 你赞同吗你来说一下呢
Shure: Do you agree? Tell us.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 你好害羞啊哈哈
Shure: You're so shy, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 你有你有想到什么反例来反驳他吗
Shure: Do you have any counterexamples to refute him?
Alice: 这题选C
Alice: Choose C for this question.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 选c选项的同学也是非常的有个性
Shure: Those who chose option C are quite unique.
Shure: 好吧好吧
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure: 那这个问题我决定二二二
Shure: So for this question, I decide two, two, two...
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 二二给大家每人发两个ego币好吧
Shure: Two, two, each of you gets two ego coins, okay?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: Dying of laughter.
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question.
Shure: 吃止痛药打架算开挂吗
Shure: Is taking painkillers before a fight considered cheating?
Lucia: 这跟地球日都没关系啦
Lucia: This has nothing to do with Earth Day.
Alice: 这跟地球日什么关系
Alice: What's this got to do with Earth Day?
其他人：文明能干的事怎么叫开挂
Others: How can something civilized be considered cheating?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 已经有同学发现了盲点哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Someone already spotted the flaw, hahaha.
Alice: 是我们从弱智8找的问题
Alice: We found this question from Stupid Questions 8.
其他人：上一个也是吗
Others: Was the last one from there too?
Alice: 是
Alice: Yes.
其他人：明显是
Others: Obviously.
Lucia: 明显哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Clearly, hahaha.
其他人：像一个这种东西
Others: Something like that.
其他人：一看就是中文高质量语料不行的是吧
Others: You can tell it's not high-quality Chinese material, right?
Shure: 这种大家换一个问题吧
Shure: Everyone, let's switch to another question.
Jake: 哈没有更多了
Jake: Haha, no more questions left.
Jake: 但是最后有一个问题啊
Jake: But there's one last question.
其他人：也不是说不可以
Others: Not that it's impossible.
其他人：可以补背门夹过的吗
Others: Can we skip this one?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 他的答案非常的好
Shure: His answer is very good.
Lucia: 相似相融哈哈哈
Lucia: Similar and harmonious, hahaha.
Shure: 必须再奖励一个
Shure: Definitely deserves another reward.
Shure: 现在收获非常颇丰
Shure: We've gained quite a lot now.
Shure: 再下一个吧
Shure: Let's go to the next one.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 不孕不育会遗传吗
Shure: Is infertility hereditary?
Shure: 大家觉得
Shure: What do you all think
其他人：试管说试管代孕的方法
Others: About using IVF and surrogacy?
Alice: 这是不是要被逼了
Alice: Isn't that kind of forced?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 你看二位二位学者
Shure: Look at you two scholars
Lucia: 啊植物的三倍体是吧
Lucia: Oh, you're talking about triploid plants?
Shure: 来来来这个是
Shure: Here, here, this is...
Jake:还有一个问题
Jake: There's another question
Shure: 那这个是什么
Shure: So what is this?
Jake: 之前
Jake: Previously
Jake: 到第14题中间有一个
Jake: There was a question in the middle of question 14
Jake: 其实只有13题对
Jake: Actually, there are only 13 questions, right?
Shure: 对刚刚有一个旗号
Shure: Yeah, there was a flag just now
Shure: 没有大家有发现吗
Shure: Did anyone notice?
Shure: 这是一个彩蛋问题
Shure: This is an Easter egg question
Shure: 这个是一个5分的问题
Shure: This question is worth 5 points
Shure: CLC这是一个竖
Shure: CLC, this is a vertical...
其他人：C
Others: C
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
其他人：那那个重复的是什么题
Others: So what was the duplicate question?
Shure: 重复的就是为了迷惑你
Shure: The duplicate is to confuse you
Shure: 所以他遗漏了啊
Shure: So it was missed, right?
Shure: 那重复的不算
Shure: The duplicate doesn't count
Shure: 那个遗漏了哪
Shure: So where was it missed?
Shure: 哪个旗号
Shure: Which flag?
Shure: 大家有注意到吗
Shure: Did anyone notice?
其他人：0-13题
Others: Questions 0-13
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Tasha: 好吗
Tasha: Alright?
Shure: 啊 0-13对
Shure: Ah, 0-13, right
Shure: 0-13他他说7
Shure: 0-13, he said 7
Lucia: 九随便说九
Lucia: Nine, just say nine
Shure: 9
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：12
Others: 12
Tasha: 这什么东西
Tasha: What is this?
Shure: 这这这位同学呢
Shure: This, this, this student here...
Tasha: 不是90吗
Tasha: Isn't it 90?
其他人：要猜一个没有的数字啊
Others: You need to guess a number that hasn't been guessed.
其他人：对99
Others: Yes, 99.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 他猜过了7
Shure: He already guessed 7.
Shure: 他猜过了9
Shure: He already guessed 9.
Shure: 他猜过了12
Shure: He already guessed 12.
其他人：0-13对0-13
Others: 0-13, yes, 0-13.
Shure: 对 0-13里面
Shure: Yes, within 0-13.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 13就是上一集哈哈
Shure: 13 was in the last episode, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:看来会赢
Jake: Looks like we might win.
Alice: 老师这种难题
Alice: Teacher, such tough questions.
Alice: 我们家刘婷就不参加了
Alice: My Liu Ting won't participate.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 猜一个吧
Shure: Just guess one.
Shure: 十十难难道要要遗落了吗
Shure: Ten, ten, is it going to be left out?
其他人：10
Others: 10.
Shure: 这个给大家缩小一下范围
Shure: Let me narrow it down for everyone.
其他人：5
Others: 5.
Shure: 在啊这个数它不是一个质数
Shure: This number, it's not a prime.
Lucia:  4
Lucia: 4.
Tasha: 帮我说个3
Tasha: Say 3 for me.
Tasha: 算什么
Tasha: What is it?
其他人：  4
Others: 4.
Shure: 8你
Shure: 8, you.
Shure: 继续 12
Shure: Keep going, 12.
Tasha: 11
Tasha: 11.
Lucia: 6
Lucia: 6.
Shure: 7是质数
Shure: 7 is a prime number.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 到底在说什么东西
Tasha: What are you even talking about?
Alice: 不是质数到底在说什么东西啊
Alice: Not a prime number? What are you talking about?
Shure: 5也是质数
Shure: 5 is also a prime number.
Tasha: 为什么我能精准的命中这些东西
Tasha: Why can I hit these things so accurately?
其他人：哎呀已经排除掉一大半了
Others: Oh, we've already eliminated more than half.
Tasha: 你们在说什么
Tasha: What are you talking about?
其他人：二三五七1113都不15
Others: Two, three, five, seven, eleven, thirteen, not fifteen.
其他人：没剩几个了
Others: Not many left.
Alice: 一人猜一个
Alice: Everyone guess one.
Alice: 5是质数哈哈哈哈
Alice: 5 is a prime number, hahaha.
Shure: 5是指数哈
Shure: 5 is an index, haha.
其他人：7年没学过数学了
Others: Haven't studied math in 7 years.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 他坚持是5
Shure: He insists it's 5.
Shure: 那我们也没有办法
Shure: Well, there's nothing we can do.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 您您8
Shure: You, you, 8.
其他人：不是质数 还是是质敉
Others: Not a prime number, or is it?
Shure: 不是指数
Shure: Not an index.
Shure: 猜一个猜一个猜一个猜一个
Shure: Guess one, guess one, guess one.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 给面给面给面
Shure: Give face, give face, give face.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 合理啊
Tasha: Makes sense.
Shure: 他给我面子
Shure: He gives me face.
Shure: 我的室友们他给我面子
Shure: My roommates, he gives me face.
Shure: 好吧好吧那
Shure: Alright, alright then.
Jake: 翻翻呗
Jake: Flip it.
Shure: 我我记住了是6
Shure: I, I remember, it's 6.
Alice: 没人猜啊
Alice: No one guessed?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Alice:6我是
Alice: 6, I am.
Shure: 所以没人猜
Shure: So no one guessed.
Jake: 确实没人猜啊
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed.
Shure: 所以所以我们这个大奖只能流 掉
Shure: So, so, this big prize has to flow away.
Tasha: 学的很好
Tasha: Learned well.
Tasha: 到底是几啊
Tasha: What is the number?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈是几啊是几啊
Tasha: Haha, what is the number, what is the number?
Alice: 6
Alice: 6.
Shure: 6
Shure: 6.
Jake: 确实一个人都没猜到99倒是有人猜
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed it, but someone guessed 99.
其他人：给我5个吧
Others: Give me 5.
Shure: 那
Shure: Then.
Shure: 我们其实就应该到我们的action time了
Shure: We should actually get to our action time.
Shure: 就我们的拍卖时间
Shure: To our auction time.
Shure: 那我们先有请我们的host
Shure: Let's first invite our host.
Shure: 我们的这房间的主人们
Shure: The owners of this room.
Shure: 先来拍一拍东西
Shure: Let's take some pictures first.
Shure: 来掌声有请第一位
Shure: A round of applause for the first one.
Alice: 不是我还没拿
Alice: No, I haven't got it yet.
Jake: 我们我们先统计一下币
Jake: Let's first count the coins we have.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 大家手上都有多少币
Shure: How many coins does everyone have?
Tasha: 工作人员为什么没有币
Tasha: Why don't the staff have any coins?
Tasha: 我拍什么东西
Tasha: What am I supposed to take pictures of?
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No...
其他人：你有几个
Others: How many do you have?
其他人：8个
Others: Eight.
其他人：我也有8个
Others: I also have eight.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 我是不是也得把我的小狗接上来
Lucia: Should I bring my puppy up too?
Alice: 你不是有那个水母灯吗
Alice: Don't you have that jellyfish lamp?
Katrina: 你们俩一人一只小狗吗
Katrina: Do you both have a puppy each?
Lucia: 水母没有灯珠
Lucia: The jellyfish doesn't have any light bulbs.
Katrina: 我没有灯珠
Katrina: I don't have any bulbs.
Lucia: 他现在不是灯
Lucia: It's not a lamp now.
Katrina: 他现在不是灯
Katrina: It's not a lamp now.
Lucia: 他只是水母
Lucia: It's just a jellyfish.
Alice: 那把狗请上来
Alice: Then bring the puppy up.
Lucia: 哈哈行
Lucia: Haha okay.
Katrina: 哈哈行
Katrina: Haha okay.
Lucia: 我去请狗了
Lucia: I'll go get the puppy.
Shure: 你回来你回来吧
Shure: Come back, come back.
其他人：使用范围有限
Others: Limited usage.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:刘婷带了一本书说要把那个带过来
Alice: Liu Ting brought a book saying she wanted to bring that over.
Katrina: 他可以调的
Katrina: It can be adjusted.
Katrina: 好像他可以掰开
Katrina: It seems it can be opened up.
Shure: 天呐我怎么感觉我掉头发了
Shure: Oh my god, why do I feel like I'm losing hair?
Shure: 我这头发没了
Shure: My hair is gone.
Shure: 别动
Shure: Don't move.
其他人：近水楼台先得月
Others: Proximity to power has its privileges.
Shure: 不说好不
Shure: Didn't we agree not to say?
Shure: 往外说嘛
Shure: Say it out loud.
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha hey.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We...
Shure: 我们统计完自己手上都有多少币了吗
Shure: Have we finished counting how many coins we each have?
Shure: 来来报个数
Shure: Come on, report your numbers.
Katrina: 啥呀
Katrina: What?
Shure: 自己手上有多少币
Shure: How many coins you have.
Alice: 20
Alice: 20.
Shure: 那个谢外
Shure: Thank you, outside...
Shure: 外面的场记
Shure: The scene recorder outside.
Shure: 谢宾主来新民主
Shure: Thank the host for the new democracy.
Shure: 哎记一下账本
Shure: Hey, note it in the ledger.
Shure: 现在大家手里的币子
Shure: The coins everyone has now.
其他人：我记
Others: I'll note it.
Shure: 对你记
Shure: Yeah, you note it.
Shure: 因为你到
Shure: Because you...
Shure: 到时候发钱包嘛
Shure: You'll be distributing the wallets later.
Katrina: 多少个 15
Katrina: How many? 15.
Shure: 呃报一个姓名或者代号
Shure: Uh, report a name or a code.
Katrina: 小杜呗小杜小杜小杜
Katrina: Little Du, Little Du, Little Du.
Shure: 小杜小杜有15个币子
Shure: Little Du has 15 coins.
Katrina: 小杜哈哈
Katrina: Little Du, haha.
Katrina: 非要加儿哦
Katrina: Must add the "er" sound.
Alice: 小度小度
Alice: Little Du, Little Du.
其他人：那个杜啊
Others: That Du, huh.
Shure: 杜安迪的杜哈哈哈
Shure: Du Andy's Du, hahaha.
Tasha: 他有15个币
Tasha: He has 15 coins.
Shure: 这位这位同学
Shure: This, this student.
其他人：11
Others: 11.
Shure: 11
Shure: 11.
其他人：小毕哈哈哈
Others: Little Bi, hahaha.
其他人：多少个12个
Others: How many? 12.
Shure: 11
Shure: 11.
其他人：还有谁
Others: Who else?
其他人：我们俩都18个
Others: Both of us have 18.
其他人：你是谁
Others: Who are you?
其他人：小L你也是小L
Others: Little L, you're Little L.
其他人：那我就大L吧
Others: Then I'll be Big L.
其他人：XL
Others: XL.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
其他人：我坐我坐
Others: I'll sit, I'll sit.
其他人：我的小马啊
Others: My little pony.
Lucia: 行行谢谢你
Lucia: Okay, okay, thank you.
Tasha: 我是智性恋你懂吗
Tasha: I'm sapiosexual, you know?
其他人： 智性恋嗯多丑都行
Others: Sapiosexual, huh, doesn't matter how ugly.
Tasha: 哈哈哈是这样子的
Tasha: Hahaha, that's right.
其他人： 是这样子
Others: That's right.
Tasha: 嗯我是智性恋
Tasha: Yeah, I'm sapiosexual.
Tasha: 知道什么叫致性恋吗
Tasha: Do you know what sapiosexual means?
Tasha:  JK JK是什么啊
Tasha: JK, what's JK?
Tasha: 啊JK智性恋
Tasha: Ah, JK sapiosexual.
Tasha: 智性恋
Tasha: Sapiosexual.
Shure: 唱吧唱吧
Shure: Sing, sing.
Shure: 谢斌竹谢斌竹记完了吗
Shure: Thank you Binzhu, did you finish writing?
其他人：记好了记好了
Others: Yes, it's done.
Shure: 还有一个
Shure: There's one more.
Shure: 那个楠楠有两个
Shure: Nan Nan has two.
其他人：就两个
Others: Just two.
其他人：我要贿赂他
Others: I want to bribe him.
其他人：他没给我
Others: He didn't give me.
Shure: 主要老板
Shure: Mainly the boss.
Shure: 老板一直盯着我
Shure: The boss is always watching me.
Shure: 我这不好不好做事
Shure: It's hard to get things done.
Alice: 暗箱操作
Alice: Underhanded operation.
Shure: 来来来你要怎么贿赂我
Shure: Come on, come on, how do you want to bribe me?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 给给给给你3个吧
Shure: Here, here, I'll give you three.
Shure: 给你凑一下5个吧好吧
Shure: I'll round it up to five for you, okay?
Jake: 好那我们就开始
Jake: Alright, let's get started.
Shure: 好开始先
Shure: Okay, let's start first.
Shure: 是不是房间参观
Shure: Are we touring the rooms?
Jake: 先先拍吧
Jake: Let's film first.
Shure: 好那就先拍吧
Shure: Okay, let's film first.
Shure: 把
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 这把这一层的任务咱们大家都做完先
Shure: Let's all finish the tasks on this floor first.
Tasha: 有助于培养感情
Tasha: It helps build relationships.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay
Shure: 那我们进入到了激动人心的auction time
Shure: Now we enter the exciting auction time.
Shure: 拍卖时间
Shure: Auction time.
Shure: 下面有请我们的第一位拍品
Shure: Next, let's welcome our first auction item.
Shure: 不是那个哎呦我他怎么断了呢
Shure: Oh no, how did it break?
Shure: 老板你干什么的老板
Shure: Boss, what are you doing?
Tasha: 智性恋啊
Tasha: Sapiosexual, huh?
Tasha: 这个绝对智性
Tasha: This is definitely sapiosexual.
Katrina: 是我们先来是吗
Katrina: Are we going first?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 啊我吗
Lucia: Oh, is it me?
Lucia: 他没有灯
Lucia: It doesn't have a light.
Lucia: 而且我的那个欧根纱
Lucia: Also, my organza...
Lucia: 我发现贴到墙上之后就不好再剪了
Lucia: I found that once it's stuck to the wall, it's hard to cut again.
Lucia: 所以我就光这样大概做了一下
Lucia: So I just roughly did it like this.
Tasha: 身体非常好
Tasha: The body is very good.
Lucia: 理论上说里面应该有一个灯珠
Lucia: Theoretically, there should be a light inside.
Lucia: 但是他没有
Lucia: But there isn't.
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 对而且我没有热胶枪
Lucia: And I don't have a hot glue gun.
Shure: 来吧第第第一位拍拍卖的同学
Shure: Alright, next, the first student to auction.
Lucia: 所以这个这个角我是粘住的
Lucia: So I glued this corner.
Lucia: 但是这个没粘住
Lucia: But this part isn't glued.
Shure: 来介绍一下自己的拍品
Shure: Please introduce your auction item.
Shure: 就路亚同学先来吧
Shure: Let's have Lucia go first.
Lucia: 啊我来吗
Lucia: Oh, should I?
Lucia: 好吧稍等一下
Lucia: Okay, just a moment.
Lucia: 那我就还是用这个小狗吧
Lucia: Then I'll just use this little dog.
Shure: 我来一个
Shure: I'll do one.
Lucia: 如果如果我在接下来的如果
Lucia: If, if in the next...
Lucia: 我在接下来的5分钟之内
Lucia: In the next 5 minutes...
Lucia: 把那个水母修好了
Lucia: I can fix that jellyfish...
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Everyone else:
Lucia: 我就我就再我就再来一轮
Lucia: Then I'll do another round.
Lucia: 就是现在我就只能用这只小狗了
Lucia: For now, I can only use this little dog.
Lucia: 对它是一个纸箱小狗
Lucia: Yes, it's a cardboard dog.
Lucia: 然后本来是做好
Lucia: It was originally made to...
Lucia: 是为了放在我们这个房子的一楼门口
Lucia: Put at the entrance of our house on the first floor.
Lucia: 然后左右各一个就相当于一个石狮子
Lucia: One on each side, like stone lions.
Lucia: 不过它只是一只纸狗
Lucia: But it's just a paper dog.
Lucia: 对然后因为因为我的水母灯
Lucia: Yeah, and because my jellyfish lamp...
Lucia: 他因为一些状况他没有灯珠
Lucia: Due to some issues, it doesn't have any bulbs.
Lucia: 并且就是这个腿没有站稳
Lucia: And the leg isn't stable.
Lucia: 所以我决定
Lucia: So I decided...
Lucia: 先用这个小狗来代替他的位置
Lucia: To use this little dog as a replacement.
Lucia: 然后如果有喜欢他的朋友们就可
Lucia: If anyone likes it, they can...
Lucia: 以尝试出一下价
Lucia: Try to bid for it.
Lucia: 好像没有什么其他可介绍的
Lucia: There's not much else to introduce.
Lucia: 要不先这样哈哈
Lucia: So let's leave it at that, haha.
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 我我有一点
Tasha: I... I have a bit...
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 呃对
Shure: Uh, yeah...
Shure: 这个路亚同学的这个拍品
Shure: This item from Luya...
Shure: 就是
Shure: Well...
Shure: 可能跟我们的这个Eagle life的主题
Shure: It kind of relates to our Eagle Life theme.
Shure: 比较相关
Shure: It's made from...
Shure: 就是它是用我们这两天拆的
Shure: Some of the boxes we've unpacked over the past couple of days.
Shure: 快递的一些箱子
Shure: A few little crafts.
Shure: 做的一些小的手工品
Shure: It's quite eco-friendly.
Shure: 还是比较环保比较eco的
Shure: Yeah, it's pretty environmentally friendly.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 起拍价
Shure: Starting bid...
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 一一个一个一个
Shure: One... one... one...
Shure: 币子
Shure: Coin.
Shure: 哪位同学好
Shure: Any takers?
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 我们的小杜出来一个beat
Shure: Our little Du made a bid.
Alice: 拍卖呢
Alice: The auction...
Tasha: 小狗小狗啊啊
Tasha: The little dog, the little dog, ah...
Shure: 我们的哎
Shure: Our... hey...
Shure: 刚才他他叫什么来着
Shure: What was his name again?
Jake: 黄儿
Jake: Huang'er.
Shure: 王导是吗
Shure: Director Wang, right?
Alice: 黄儿
Alice: Huang'er.
Shure: 黄导是吗
Shure: Director Huang, right?
Jake:小H
Jake: Little H.
Shure: 啊黄导出了两个币子
Shure: Ah, Director Huang bid two coins.
Shure: 还有更高的吗
Shure: Is there anything higher?
Shure: 两个币子一次
Shure: Two coins once.
Shure: 两个币子两次
Shure: Two coins twice.
Shure: 两个币子三次
Shure: Two coins three times.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold!
Lucia: 呜
Lucia: Woo!
Lucia: 哪哪哪位同学来着
Lucia: Which student was it again?
Shure: 好现在交还你的两个币子
Shure: Alright, now returning your two coins.
Jake: 你要记了
Jake: You need to remember.
其他人：减两个币那个币给谁了
Others: Who got the two coins deducted?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 给了路亚
Shure: They went to Luya.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: 都给我了哈哈哈哈
Lucia: I got them all, hahaha!
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 好了他的b全部转移了
Tasha: Alright, all his coins are transferred.
Shure: 路亚现在是两个bees对
Shure: Luya now has two coins, right?
Lucia: 对谢谢
Lucia: Yes, thank you.
其他人：你现在一共多少个
Others: How many do you have in total now?
Lucia: 两个这不刚开始吗哈哈
Lucia: Two, isn't this just the beginning? Haha!
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Shure: 那我们下面有请第2个拍品
Shure: Now, let's move on to the second auction item.
Lucia: 我去我的压花还没拆突然想起来
Lucia: Oh, I just remembered I haven't unpacked my pressed flowers.
Tasha: 接下来拍啥
Tasha: What's next in the auction?
Katrina: 我们刚开始的时候
Katrina: When we first started,
Katrina: 给大家每人买了一束鲜花
Katrina: we bought everyone a bouquet of fresh flowers.
Katrina: 然后放花瓶里养
Katrina: Then we kept them in vases.
Katrina: 然后买的是那个白百合和黄的百合
Katrina: We bought white lilies and yellow lilies,
Katrina: 还有那个康乃馨和芍药
Katrina: as well as carnations and peonies.
Katrina: 然后这都是我们自己种的
Katrina: And we grew them ourselves.
Katrina: 然后就它慢慢开了以后
Katrina: Once they bloomed,
Katrina: 我们就把它放在那个压花器里面压
Katrina: we pressed them in a flower press.
Katrina: 然后压了两三天以后
Katrina: After pressing them for two or three days,
Katrina: 晒干以后
Katrina: and drying them,
Katrina: 给大家做成这种书签
Katrina: we made them into bookmarks for everyone.
Katrina: 然后就是对
Katrina: And then, yeah,
Katrina: 就可以放书里面
Katrina: you can put them in books.
Katrina: 然后芍药的话还是挺香的
Katrina: The peonies still smell quite nice.
Katrina: 然后还有这种明信片
Katrina: And we also have these postcards.
Katrina: 就是明信片的话就是会少一点
Katrina: There are fewer postcards, though.
Katrina: 就是放了几片花瓣贴在上面
Katrina: I just put a few petals on it.
Katrina: 然后呃
Katrina: And then, uh...
Katrina: 就是长这个样子
Katrina: It looks like this.
Katrina: 然后我这个怎么定价呢
Katrina: So, how should I price this?
其他人：大家拍一下
Others: Everyone, take a look.
其他人： 起拍价
Others: Starting price.
Shure: 样呢
Shure: How about this?
Katrina: 呃两个就一ego币起拍
Katrina: Uh, start with one ego coin for two of them.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 一份明信片加
Shure: One postcard and...
Katrina: 一个书签
Katrina: One bookmark.
Shure: 一个书签
Shure: One bookmark.
Shure: 你这个量有点多
Shure: You've got quite a lot here.
Shure: 要不我们重新定一下价呢
Shure: How about we reprice it?
Shure: 那我们就是四个
Shure: So, let's do four...
Shure: 四个来对两
Shure: Four for two.
Shure: 2+2 好吧
Shure: 2+2, okay?
Katrina: 我来分一下让他们先拍
Katrina: I'll split it up and they can bid first.
Shure: 两个书签加两个明信片
Shure: Two bookmarks and two postcards.
Shure: 起拍价一个ego币
Shure: Starting bid, one ego coin.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Shure: 这个非常吉利啊
Shure: This is very lucky.
Shure: 两个一次三个
Shure: Two once, three...
其他人：三个
Others: Three.
其他人： 哦哦很多组啊多组啊那得4那得4
Others: Oh, there are many sets, should be 4, should be 4.
其他人：我们一个人一个不就行了吗
Others: Can’t each of us just have one?
其他人： 哦哦那得4那得4
Others: Oh, should be 4, should be 4.
Shure: 落子无悔啊
Shure: No regrets.
Shure: 落子无悔我们
Shure: No regrets for us.
Shure: 三个一次
Shure: Three once.
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three twice.
Shure: 三个三次
Shure: Three times.
Jake: 自己人后台无价
Jake: For us, it's priceless backstage.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold.
Shure: 好的我们第一组书签
Shure: Alright, our first set of bookmarks...
Shure: 家明信片
Shure: Plus postcards.
其他人： 你先不要着急，我先把钱攒够的
Others: Don’t rush, I need to save enough money first.
Jake: 还贷款拍卖
Jake: Repay loans auction
其他人： 我的钱去哪儿了
Others: Where did my money go?
其他人： 这是自己藏的吗
Others: Did you hide it yourself?
其他人： 自己藏自己找是吧
Others: Did you hide it and now you're looking for it?
其他人：自己藏的自己找是吧
Others: You hid it yourself and now you're looking for it?
其他人：私藏钱呢
Others: Hiding money privately?
其他人：我去找它我藏的
Others: I'll go find it where I hid it.
其他人：我已经散尽家财了
Others: I've already spent all my family money.
其他人：我只参与了一次成功的拍卖
Others: I only succeeded in one auction.
其他人：好我已经散尽家财了
Others: Okay, I've already spent all my family money.
Shure: 好这是第一组
Shure: Okay, this is the first group.
Shure: 第二组起拍
Shure: Second group, start bidding.
Shure: 还有还有两组啊
Shure: There are still two more groups.
其他人：一个两个两个三个
Others: One, two, two, three.
Shure: 两个三个
Shure: Two, three.
Shure: 三个一次三个
Shure: Three once, three.
Shure: 两次 3个
Shure: Twice, three.
Jake:找不到了
Jake: Can't find it.
Shure: 还有没有加价的
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure: 了last time
Shure: Last time.
Jake:恩
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: so
Shure: So.
Shure: 是这么喊的吧
Shure: Is this how it's called?
Shure: 好还有最后一组
Shure: Okay, there's one last group.
Shure: 起拍价1 一个两个
Shure: Starting price 1, one, two.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个一次两个两次哦
Shure: Two once, two twice, oh.
其他人：三个
Others: Three.
Katrina: 我爽了
Katrina: I'm so happy.
Shure: 3个一次还有人要加价吗
Shure: Three once, anyone want to bid higher?
其他人：4个四个
Others: Four, four.
Shure: 4个哎呦
Shure: Four, wow.
Jake: 啊这么有钱
Jake: Ah, so rich.
其他人：我有150个
Others: I have 150.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈啊账账本不算啊
Shure: Hahaha, account books don't count.
其他人：我有四个啊
Others: I have four.
Shure: 啊他他就想想四个来吧
Shure: Ah, he just wants to think about four, right?
Shure: 那四个一次四个两次
Shure: So, four at a time, twice.
其他人： 我操没人扛价了
Others: Damn, no one's bidding anymore.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: soul四个三次
Shure: Soul four times, three times.
Katrina: 笑死了好谢谢老板
Katrina: I'm dying of laughter, thanks, boss.
Shure: 记好账啊记好账
Shure: Make sure to keep track of the accounts, okay?
Shure: 那剩下这些就一起出来一次
Shure: The rest, let's just do them all at once.
其他人： 还我吧破产
Others: I'm going bankrupt.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 行吧还是你想留留几个
Shure: Alright, or do you want to keep a few?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 等我把我的东西卖了我替你还上债爹
Tasha: I'll sell my stuff and pay off your debt, dad.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 我留着吧
Katrina: I'll keep them.
Shure: 留着OK好的
Shure: Keep them, okay, sure.
其他人：你一共几个
Others: How many do you have in total?
Shure: 不是币子币子
Shure: Not coins, coins.
Katrina: 我现在是原先4个那是10个
Katrina: I have four originally, now it's ten.
其他人：谢斌竹负4
Others: Xie Binzhu minus 4.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Shure: 可以贷款
Shure: You can get a loan.
Lucia: 你不是150个吗
Lucia: Don't you have 150?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 然后刚刚他们两位的还还是他们两位
Shure: And then those two just now, still those two.
Shure: 他们三位每人是
Shure: Each of the three of them...
其他人：我减了3
Others: I deducted 3.
Shure: 减了3你减了没
Shure: Deducted 3, did you deduct?
其他人：没没没买没没花出去
Others: No, no, didn't buy, didn't spend.
Shure: 还还有谁花了三来着啊他三
Shure: And who else spent three? Oh, he spent three.
其他人：还一共多少了哦
Others: How much in total now?
其他人：我现在就没了
Others: I have nothing left now.
其他人：我已经没了
Others: I'm already out.
Shure: 他那个黄导黄导
Shure: That guy, Director Huang, Director Huang.
其他人：他你一共多少了
Others: How much do you have in total?
其他人：他说十币
Others: He said ten coins.
其他人：我没有其他的花销
Others: I have no other expenses.
Shure: 他没变他没变还是酒嗯
Shure: He hasn't changed, he hasn't changed, it's still alcohol, hmm.
其他人：   这两个也没变
Others: These two haven't changed either.
其他人：我们仨都没花出去钱
Others: None of us three spent any money.
其他人： 对呀 这一轮没花出去
Others: Yeah, we didn't spend any this round.
其他人：太可惜了
Others: Such a pity.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Shure: 非常可惜
Shure: Very unfortunate.
Shure: 那个请那个场务人员不要哄抬物价啊
Shure: Please, staff, don't inflate the prices, okay?
Shure: 来吧下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, next bidder, please.
Shure: welcome any host animal
Shure: Welcome any host animal.
Tasha: 你上吧
Tasha: You go ahead.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: I'll go.
Tasha: 不是你上吗
Tasha: Weren't you going?
Tasha: 啊刷你先上
Tasha: Ah, Choiszt, you go first.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我的我的CP
Lucia: Hahaha, my CP.
Lucia: 我的CP来了
Lucia: My CP is here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 这是
Shure: This is...
Alice: Lucia的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's CP dog.
Shure: 他叫二狗
Shure: His name is Ergou.
Alice: Lucia狗的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's CP dog.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈突然打人
Lucia: Hahahahahaha, suddenly hitting people.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice: 大家可以叫他二哈
Alice: You can call him Erha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Alice: 啊其实我本来准备的是水仙种子
Alice: Ah, actually, I was originally going to prepare narcissus seeds.
Alice: 但是我P的太狠了
Alice: But I procrastinated too much.
Alice: 我忘买了
Alice: I forgot to buy them.
Alice: 然后就做了一只纸狗
Alice: So, I made a paper dog instead.
Alice: 然后这个纸狗的话赠送一个卫生纸
Alice: And this paper dog comes with a tissue.
Alice: 捏的花已经别到他的耳朵上了
Alice: The flower I made is already pinned to his ear.
Alice: 好就这样
Alice: Alright, that's it.
Alice: 起拍价一个
Alice: Starting bid is one.
Alice: 大家不用哄抬
Alice: No need to inflate the price.
Alice: 因为我还会捏
Alice: Because I can make more.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 一个起拍
Alice: Starting bid is one.
其他人：一个
Others: One
Shure: 一个一个一次
Shure: One at a time
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
其他人：就到此为止吧
Others: Let's stop here
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 一个两次这可比露西亚多一朵花呀
Shure: Twice, that's one more flower than Lucia
Tasha: 哄抬一下
Tasha: Raise it up
Shure: 那我们
Shure: So we
Tasha: 我赚到的
Tasha: I earned it
Tasha: 我帮你还两个啊
Tasha: I'll repay you two
其他人：两个
Others: Two
Shure: 哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh no, oh no
Tasha: 啊我说哄抬我的
Tasha: Oh, I said raise mine
Tasha: 我的哈哈
Tasha: Mine, haha
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two
Jake: 哪来的钱哈
Jake: Where did the money come from?
其他人：我我我受到蒙骗
Others: I, I, I was deceived
Lucia: 我收到东西
Lucia: I received something
其他人：我退出拍卖了
Others: I'm out of the auction
其他人：   我退出拍卖
Shure: 那就还是一个
Shure: So still one
其他人：一个起拍价买到OK
Others: Bought at the starting price, okay
Shure: SOD
Tasha: 上
Tasha: Up
Shure: 有没有敲得更响一点的东西
Shure: Is there something that can make a louder noise?
Tasha: 上小弟
Tasha: Go, little bro
Tasha: 付4块钱
Tasha: Pay 4 bucks
Tasha: 我帮你还了
Tasha: I'll repay you
Alice: 给你留着吧
Alice: Keep it for yourself
Alice: 你多买点
Alice: Buy more
Tasha: 你站你去就行
Tasha: Just stand there, it's fine
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人： 我来卖东西了
Others: I'm here to sell something
其他人：你什么时候出来的
Others: When did you come out?
Lucia: 你什么哎
Lucia: What, hey
Lucia: 对哈哈
Lucia: Yes, haha
其他人： 我可以和代购
Others: I can work with purchasing agents
其他人：我是代购
Others: I'm a purchasing agent.
Tasha: 代购
Tasha: Purchasing agent.
其他人：这个是我姐做的
Others: This was made by my sister.
Tasha: 哈哈哈呃
Tasha: Hahaha, uh.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
其他人：想一下怎么拆
Others: Think about how to open it.
Jake: 想一下怎么变
Jake: Think about how to transform it.
其他人： 就这么说吧这个东西从主题上说
Others: Let's just say, from a thematic standpoint,
其他人：他是一个很环保的种子书签
Others: It's a very eco-friendly seed bookmark.
其他人： 然后你们把这个东西
Others: Then you take this thing,
其他人： 倒在倒在那个土壤里
Others: And pour it into the soil.
其他人：浇水太阳能生成种子
Others: Water it, and the sunlight will generate seeds.
其他人：这是商品的实啊
Others: This is the actual product.
其他人：太阳花上面的实际价值
Others: The actual value of the sunflower on it.
其他人：它上面的实际价值就非常屌
Others: Its actual value is really awesome.
其他人： 你们买了这个就和我姐建立了联系
Others: By buying this, you'll establish a connection with my sister.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：我姐是个什么人
Others: What kind of person is my sister?
其他人：是一个一晚上让两个男人说谎无数次的女人
Others: She's a woman who can make two men lie countless times in one night.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
其他人： 你们只要认识了她 你们就能一帆风顺
Others: Once you get to know her, everything will go smoothly for you.
其他人： 一个起拍      1go 币起拍
Others: Starting bid, 1 GO coin.
其他人：一把吗还是一个
Others: One lot or just one?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Shure: 你这不行
Shure: You can't do this.
Shure: 市场监督管理局提醒您
Shure: The Market Supervision Bureau reminds you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Shure: 你这总共有几个
Shure: How many do you have in total?
其他人： 总共6个
Others: A total of six.
Shure: 6个总共6个
Shure: Six, a total of six.
Shure: 两个一个吧
Shure: Two in each lot, right?
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我们不希望东西它不是成对出现的
Shure: We don't want things to appear in odd numbers.
Shure: 对吧多孤独啊
Shure: Right? It's so lonely.
Shure: 好的那我们一egb
Shure: Alright, let's start with one EGB.
Shure: 两个种子包
Shure: Two seed packets.
Shure: 起拍 2
Shure: Starting bid is 2.
其他人：2
Others: 2.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人： 走一下流程是吗
Others: Are we just going through the motions?
Shure: 两个还有更高的吗
Shure: Two, any higher bids?
Shure: 两个依次
Shure: Two, going once.
其他人：3
Others: 3.
Shure: 哎呦黄岛还是大气
Shure: Wow, Nicous is generous.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 3个3个一次还有人要加价吗
Shure: 3, 3, going once, any more bids?
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: 3, going twice.
Shure: 三个三次成交
Shure: 3, going three times, sold!
Shure: 好的第二轮拍卖
Shure: Alright, second round of the auction.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 一一个起拍一两个2两个一次
Shure: One, starting bid is 1, two for 2, going once.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, going twice.
Shure: 两个3次
Shure: Two, going three times.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold!
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：最后一个
Others: Last one.
其他人：最后一份
Others: Last item.
Shure: 啊还有最后一份
Shure: Ah, there's one last item.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two, going once.
Shure: 还有出更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, going twice.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Tasha: 大声快点
Tasha: Louder, faster.
Shure: 还有还有
Shure: Any more bids?
Shure: 出嫁了吗
Shure: Sold?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
其他人： 三次
Others: Three times.
Shure: 好好四个一次
Shure: Alright, four, going once.
Tasha: 好好哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha, good one!
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four times, twice.
Shure: 四个三次成交
Shure: Four times, three deals.
Tasha: 怎么样好
Tasha: How about it, good?
Tasha: 回回你俩好
Tasha: Every time, you two are good.
其他人：爽了姐哈哈哈
Others: Awesome, sis! Haha.
Shure: OK我们host auction部分还有
Shure: Okay, our host auction part still has...
Tasha: 给你这是黄牛价
Tasha: Here you go, this is a scalper price.
Shure: 大家要拍卖物品吗
Shure: Does anyone want to auction items?
Tasha: 来
Tasha: Come on.
Lucia: 我现在下去做去哈哈
Lucia: I'll go down and do it now, haha.
Shure: okay好的
Shure: Okay, got it.
Lucia: 真的我想起来我那没拆
Lucia: Really, I just remembered I haven't unpacked it.
Shure: 那
Shure: Then...
Lucia: 大家先玩着
Lucia: You guys play first.
Shure: 那现在没有了这个host auction的部分
Shure: So now, there's no more of the host auction part.
Shure: 然后我们现在进入到下一part
Shure: And now we move on to the next part.
Shure: 刚刚大家已经花了很多钱
Shure: Just now, everyone spent a lot of money
Shure: 来购入这些host的拍卖品
Shure: to buy these host auction items, right?
Shure: 对吧然后所以下一个环节
Shure: So the next segment,
Shure: 大家可以来上台
Shure: you can come on stage
Shure: 简单的进行一个自我介绍
Shure: and do a simple self-introduction.
Shure: 然后根据你自我介绍的
Shure: Based on your self-introduction,
Shure: 我们再发放一波ego币
Shure: we will give out some ego coins.
Shure: 有哪位自告奋勇的
Shure: Anyone want to volunteer
Shure: 先上来自我介绍一下
Shure: to come up and introduce yourself?
其他人：第一波有新客优惠吗
Others: Are there new customer discounts for the first wave?
Shure: 那肯定有跟你没有关系gas的环节
Shure: There definitely are, but it’s unrelated to the gas segment.
Shure: 嗯有哪位想introduction
Shure: So, anyone want to do an introduction?
Alice: 新客满三减二是吗
Alice: Is it a three-for-two deal for new customers?
Shure: 没有没有也
Shure: No, no. Also...
Shure: 那个可以不介绍
Shure: You can skip the introduction.
Shure: 可以给大家讲个笑话讲个故事
Shure: You can tell a joke or a story.
Shure: 都可以就是只要你上台来我就会
Shure: Anything is fine, as long as you come up, I will...
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone,
Shure: 评委席就会根据表现来给各位打分
Shure: the judges will score your performance
Shure: 并且发放ego币
Shure: and give out ego coins.
Shure: 有自告奋勇的吗
Shure: Any volunteers?
Shure: 展示才艺也可以
Shure: You can also showcase your talents.
Alice: 哈哈刘婷会唱歌
Alice: Haha, Liu Ting can sing.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：你怎么不杀了我
Others: Why don't you kill me?
其他人：你先打个样
Others: You go first.
其他人：你先扣自己的币打个样
Others: You go ahead and show us how it's done.
其他人：然后你说我扣上
Others: Then you tell me to do it.
其他人：这是第一个上来加的
Others: This is the first one who added.
Shure: 我给大家当当当
Shure: I'll be your host.
其他人：扣自己的
Others: Do it yourself.
Shure: 我给大家自我介绍一下
Shure: Let me introduce myself.
Shure: 大家好
Shure: Hi everyone.
Shure: 低调低调低调
Shure: Keep it low-key, keep it low-key.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 大家好对
Shure: Hi everyone, yes.
Shure: 我叫修硕
Shure: My name is Shure.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 对我来自   大学
Shure: 然后是一位大四的文科生
Shure: And I'm a senior liberal arts student.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 怎么样怎么样
Shure: How's it, how's it?
Shure: 这个这个介绍还是不错的吧
Shure: This introduction is pretty good, right?
Shure: 你说好了
Shure: You said it well.
Shure: 那你要上来introduction一下嘛
Shure: So you need to come up and introduce yourself too.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 哎呦大家活跃一点嘛
Shure: Come on, everyone, be more lively.
Shure: 活跃一点对
Shure: Be more lively, right.
Shure: 跟大家
Shure: With everyone.
Shure: 大家都是各位的亲朋好友
Shure: You are all friends and family.
Shure: 其实也没有没有什么害羞的
Shure: There's really nothing to be shy about.
Shure: 主要就是想让其他的同学
Shure: The main thing is to let other students
Shure: 就是来也互相认识一下
Shure: come and get to know each other.
Shure: 毕竟一会还有顿晚餐呢
Shure: After all, there's dinner later.
Shure: 大家就是尬在那里也不好是吧
Shure: It wouldn't be good if everyone is awkward, right?
Shure: 没有的话我可点名了啊
Shure: If no one volunteers, I'll start calling names.
Tasha: 我靠像老师一样哈哈
Tasha: Wow, you're like a teacher, haha.
其他人：你自己先拍那两个币这个币就是新客加2
Others: You first take a picture of those two coins, this coin is for new customers, plus 2.
Shure: 对我现在啊
Shure: Yeah, I got it now.
Shure: 开始往上加
Shure: Starting to add up.
Shure: 加爆
Shure: Adding like crazy.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure: 后面的拍品会还有更好的啊
Shure: There will be better items in the later auctions.
Shure: 一个有没有人上来讲
Shure: Anyone wants to come up and talk?
Shure: 两个了啊
Shure: Two already.
其他人：你这个加法是不会有人上去的
Others: With your way of adding, no one will come up.
其他人：应该是从高往低拍
Others: It should be auctioned from high to low.
其他人：你说限时
Others: You said it's limited time.
其他人：你怎么一个一个往上加
Others: How can you keep adding one by one?
其他人：大家肯定都不上去
Others: Of course, no one will come up.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Shure: 一答10个
Shure: Answer 10.
Shure: 10个开始往下捡
Shure: Start picking from 10.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha: 多少个
Tasha: How many?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Tasha: 40 块钱
Tasha: 40 bucks.
其他人：呃大家好
Others: Uh, hello everyone.
其他人：呃我叫呃
Others: Uh, my name is uh.
其他人：杜卓宇大家可以叫我小杜
Others: Du Zhuoyu, you can call me Xiao Du.
其他人：然后我就是AK刘宇轩的小弟
Others: I'm AK Liu Yuxuan's junior.
其他人：呃我们就去年去年认识的
Others: Uh, we met last year.
其他人：然后我今年是在北京实习
Others: And I'm interning in Beijing this year.
其他人：然后过两天我就走了
Others: And I'll be leaving in a couple of days.
其他人：我就去旅游一段时间
Others: I'm going on a trip for a while.
其他人：然后等到
Others: And then.
其他人：我也是做大模型相关的内容
Others: I'm also working on large model-related stuff.